ich mir fehlen ein bisschen die worte
weil ich irgendwie das ist sehr selten
so dass sich in dem video einfach nicht
weiß was ich jetzt sagen soll
ich bin irgendwie so geflasht von so was
gerade keine ahnung etwas getan jetzt
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
leute ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's
gut bevor es wieder losgeht noch ganz
schnell am 28 04 kommt dieser merger aus
so sieht das ganze aus wir haben hinten
noch einen aufdruck dazu aber noch mehr
in den folgenden videos ich wollte doch
mal kurz sagen genau denn eigentlich
geht es heute um was ganz anderes und
zwar hab das wahrscheinlich schon am
titel gelesen obwohl ich noch gar nicht
weiß wie ich das video überhaupt nennen
werde ich glaub letzte woche war auch so
ein video in deutschland in den trends
und zwar von einem youtuber niveau an
dieser stelle schöne grüße den kenn ich
noch von früher ist ein sehr
sympathischer typ und zwar der in diesem
video 100.000 mal hintereinander
fortnight gesagt und das ganze habe ich
auch schon mal irgendwie von 203 monaten
entdeckt dass haben in amerika sehr
viele leute gemacht was ich glaube ich
gesehen habe war irgendein typ der hat
hunderttausendmal logan paul gesagt das
hat dann irgendwie 24 stunden gedauert
natürlich habe ich mir nicht hinter uns
schon angeguckt aber ich habe mir
wirklich gedacht was verleitet menschen
dazu so etwas zu machen und vor allem
wer guckt sich das dann 24 stunden an
und deswegen habe ich die leute überlegt
wir schauen uns mal zusammen einige
videos dazu an denn davon gibt sich nur
eins wir haben ganz viele verschiedene
und ja ich bin mal gespannt bei 25.000
likes sage ich hunderttausendmal alex w
naja mal sehen
das wäre schon echt witzig so aber dafür
bräuchte ich erstmal seinen
twitter-account oder so damit das
irgendwie sinn machen würde
bis dahin ist ja noch ein bisschen auf
jeden fall würde ich sagen will aber gar
nicht lange fangen sofort mal an so und
zwar habe ich irgendein video dazu schon
gesehen ich glaube das war irgendwie ich
gebe einfach mal 100.000 mal ich habe
einfach mal 100.000 mal ein
und jetzt kommt das genau das video habe
ich auch schon gesehen ich sage
hunderttausendmal fortnight so und
dieses video von mister biest war das
erste video was ich zu dem thema gesehen
hab 100.000 mal logan paul sagen hat er
17 stunden und sechs minuten für
gebraucht das video am 8 7 millionen
menschen gesehen
rund 47.000 leute haben sich glaubten
irgendwie ist das nicht so interessant
und 248.000 leute dachten sich auch was
ein cooler typ ich kann nicht glauben
dass ich das gemacht habe
skype for free cash stellt immer fordert
ist das alles gemacht und wird am ende
raus führen dass seine kamera nicht
aufgenommen hat natürlich schaut euch
jetzt nicht das ganze video ich gucke
einfach so ein paar stellen mal sehen
was da so anstellt und danach schauen
wir weiter
was ist einfach noch so gibt das ganze
mache ich allerdings über mein handy
weil ich irgendwie den sound nicht
aufnehmen kann keine ahnung dass spinnt
ein bisschen deswegen würde ich sagen
man muss ja jetzt schon so sagen der typ
hat das noch nicht einmal gesagt sieht
aber trotzdem schon extrem fertig aus
den augen ich glaube dir macht so etwas
öfter gebraucht
so sitzt ich glaube das schlimmste daran
ist wenn du irgendwie soweit 1000 bist
und das ist schon so zehn minuten geht
oder wenn nicht sogar länger
und dann merkt ja ich muss noch 100 mal
das gleiche machen ich weiß nicht wie
lange ich das aushalten würde
so wir sind jetzt bei 45 scroll einfach
mal so auf sieben stunden er hat jetzt
schon 35 1228 mal sorgenvoll gesagt ja
also noch ist ja relativ fit ich geh mal
auf ich gehe mal so kurz vors ende hier
16 stunden 55 jetzt kommt erstmal
werbung aber dass auch bemerkenswert er
hat in 17 stunden nur einer werbung
geschaltet
das dort gehe ich mal hier kurz vor die
100.000 wie man sich da wohl fühlen muss
der hat jetzt 17 stunden sein leben
damit verbracht
logan paul zu sagen da caparros ida sei
damit also das ist wirklich man muss
sich doch so danach denken ja jetzt habe
ich gerade 17 stunden meines lebens
verschwendet und er konnte am ende auch
wirklich gar nicht mehr sprechen so man
sei ja dass er total müde ist wenn man
sehr lange nicht schläft sich trotzdem
versucht zu konzentrieren dann hat das
ja sondern wirken auf einen als wir noch
mal alkohol trinken und am ende kommt er
mir auch so ein bisschen so als wäre auf
irgendwelchen anderen substanzen aber ja
alex reality alex frei aus wie alle
dialekte sie alle tricks wie alle so
jetzt habe ich gerade das nächste video
gefunden und zwar dass hier bei count to
one million in won't take the world
record das ding ist es ist
wahrscheinlich nur die eine millionen
drauf das video geht nur 25 sekunden
aber ich würde sagen wir schauen
trotzdem mal kurz rein
[Musik]
egal ob das jetzt also der hat 44 101
stunden und 22 minuten die scheiße
aufgenommen sodass hier ist das einzige
deutsche video was ich bis jetzt dazu
gefunden habt wir schauen jetzt einfach
mal wie der migros am ende aussieht also
einfach im vergleich zu dem minister
wies von eben der halt bis
hunderttausende der 100000 mal in folge
sagt habt ja gut irgendwie stopp ist
jetzt gleich weil er ist gerade bei
64.000 also im vergleich zu mister biest
sieht der echt noch schied aus ja
deswegen schauen wir mal was war noch zu
finden so als nächstes habe ich das
unfassbar geniale video ice age again
hunderttausend mal hier sind die letzten
1000 der da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt
bevor das widerrufs gesteht ich erstmal
über 15 tage habe ich das wort coaching
im leibchen hunderttausend mal gesagt ja
ach so achim titel steht sogar millionen
alter für mehr als 17 stunden am tag bei
dem stream schauen jetzt gerade 13 1068
leute zu die sich die ganze zeit diesen
typen anschauen der nur gut ski ging
sagt 13.000 menschen schauen sich das
land willkommen im jahr 2018
wie kann man denn besonders gut leute
unterhalten sagt doch einfach eine
million mal gucci ging also um das jetzt
gerade mal klarzustellen bzw
zusammenzufassen menschen setzen sich
für eine webcam und sagen einfach
100.000 mal das gleiche diese videos
werden über millionen mal geklickt und
dann gibt sachen die sind echt geil von
der produktion her
die kaum in schreien interessieren also
an sich ist es ja total dummer content
muss man einfach mal so sagen trotzdem
zieht es halt die massen an was sich
wirklich kassel sowie schauen einfach
mal rein hierbei den letzten 1000 gucci
gelenks
[Musik]
irgendwie wirken die alle als hätten
irgendwelche drogen genommen für mich
mit ihnen geschieht
stellt euch vor ihr müsst euren eltern
erzählen was sie so die letzten 17 tage
gemacht habt jeden tag live stream 17
stunden gesagt ja meine eltern werden
stolz auf mich so so wir haben jetzt die
letzten acht mal 22 1593 zuschauer
sie haben sich wahrscheinlich ein wecker
gestellt dass genau jetzt die eine
million mal gut geklappt wir das muss
ich sehen und und der typ hängt an zu
heulen
okay es ist schon irgendwie auch keine
ahnung ich weiß nicht was ich zu sagen
soll es ist natürlich auch auf
irgendeine art und weise was da
eigentlich ist es komplett behindert
ich habe einmal gesagt ob ich jetzt
danach wein würde weiß ich nicht
ich mir fehlen ein bisschen die worte
weil ich irgendwie das ist sehr selten
so dass sich in dem video einfach nicht
weiß was ich jetzt sagen soll
ich bin irgendwie so geflasht von so was
gerade keine ahnung und ob ich das
durchhalten könnte ohne zu schlafen
100.000 mal alles wie zu sagen da habe
ich das dass da einfach eine krasse
herausforderung
trotzdem weiß ich dass ich das
frühestens in der woche machen kann weil
ich jetzt bald noch eine klausur
schreiben wenn ihr darauf bock habt das
nun leichter bei 25.000 likes kann man
das vielleicht mal versuchen ja
ansonsten kommentiert gerne mal was ihr
von sowas haltet unterhält euch das oder
guckt jetzt nur um zu sehen wie die
leute dafür wecken nach 24 stunden also
leute denkt dran am 28 kommt dieser
schöne brauch ich finde vom designer ist
echt richtig frech ich kann euch nochmal
kurzem foto einbänden hier können wir
auf jeden fall auf instagram und
snapshot hast nur ein runder und wir
sehen uns dann morgen oder übermorgen
wieder ich weiß noch nicht ganz